[Music]
I want to play a little game with you
this is supposed to be my different
thing
I like mr. rate things on a scary scale
of 1 to 10 okay okay
haunted houses when it's in seven Oh say
good say six or seven you know how could
you do it one is ten five four she
doesn't get scared of anything though
doing red carpet interviews ten ten nine
no no maybe like seven seven I'm serious
no I think - that's scary interviewers
like you oh yeah good - good - am i real
good - just because it's it's no no it's
nerve-racked alone it's nerve-racking
but with everyone it's kind of just like
because let's do this yeah accidentally
liking someone's Instagram pic from 40
weeks ago oh yeah I've met a long time
but okay I say zero because it's bold
gonna do this like yeah yeah I've done
that yeah I wish I could say that - I
haven't said that I'm dumb in a long
time
just maybe since I was like 2011 11 or
12 and I remember like liking oh my god
yeah probably
probably a solid eight Oh 110 like what
are you gonna do I don't care about that
much I don't really look at the time I
just if it's good then it's good I
didn't really think it's embarrassing
from how many hop do it is 42 it is
scrolling down your crushes feed and
then all of a sudden you're like oh my
god I just doubled two years away that's
so embarrassing
I've done ten if you like the picture
than you like the picture I think you're
stalking me yeah you're like at the
bottom of their feed hey well if you're
good friends and sure yeah that's a
tendon I never even stalk anyone on
their feed if it's on my ears
it's all nice thing and then I like it
I'm adding a snapchat to your story that
was only met first Pacific that's that's
danger depends I'm almost done that I
usually yeah I've never done that so for
me that's a nine for sure because I know
oh yeah it would be yeah yeah yeah
anything for sure
I don't know I don't know what they did
how many times I would say one
forgetting the name of someone that you
just met she didn't remember our newest
high for waving back at someone who
wasn't even waving like hey Jack and
then turn around there's like this other
guy's name chuckling yeah zero for me
because it's just like it's no it's like
no no that's a 10-4 really come on I'll
give you a story when new first shooting
stranger things I mean everyone like
didn't know who you were and everyone
thought we were like total geeks this
extra like and I was afraid of the ex I
was super afraid of the extras just
because like I had never done anything
like that and this extra was like waving
at me I was like hi and you just went
give me this disgusted moan and I like
turn around and he's waving to this
other person and I just like bad my hand
[Music]
you